hi guys I just got back from Cincinnati
from that sudden trip that I told you
guys about the day before I left so if I
look a little frazzled it's because I've
had like six hours of sleep in the past
48 hours first off just thank you guys
so much for all the birthday wishes
yesterday thank you for helping me
celebrate the big three oh thank you for
24 million subscribers like that came
out of nowhere - but I wanted to talk
about why I was in Cincinnati yesterday
yesterday was Tyler's mom's memorial
service
if you don't know Tyler Tyler's the guy
who's been helping me make videos he's
been in markiplier makes like this is
Tyler Tyler's mom Cindy passed away
about a month ago and the service was
just yesterday that's why I flew in
because I promised him I would be there
and of course I'd be there so I'm
telling you this now and not before
because I just I didn't want anyone to
show up to the memorial service out of
the blue like I just didn't want that to
happen you know because I wanted to give
like the family the most space possible
and like be as supportive as I can from
a distance but you know Tyler he's he's
a friend of mine so I have a favor to
ask of you guys if you are willing to
help out if you can send him some love
send him some support send him and his
entire family some support I hate to say
but I did not even know Cindy that well
like I knew her and I've known her for a
long time but I never really got to know
her and it's it's terrible that at her
memorial is when I learned so much about
her and what an amazing person she was
I've actually told this story before but
I've left out a crucial detail I've
talked about the first time I had
surgery I got my tumor removed it was a
very painful recovery process because
they got my medication wrong basically
from the time I had the surgery until
the next morning I was in incredible
Payne because they got my pain
medication wrong the only reason that
got fixed is because Tyler's mom works
in the pharmacy at the hospital that I
was at she wasn't there when I was first
admitted so she comes in on her morning
shift her whenever it was and she knows
that I'm there he had no reason to
really know who I was or or like really
care all that much but that's just the
type of person that she was she came in
and she checked up on me she checked my
file and she saw immediately that there
was a problem
so she fixed it like the only reason
that I had my pain finally managed is
because she went out of her way to help
someone that she only knew because I was
a friend of her sons and that's just the
kind of person that she was and it was
like that story is nothing compared to
the stories that people were telling
about her so please send Tyler all the
love in the world that you can send his
family stuff I'll provide links to his
Twitter in the description below to send
messages of goodwill because I know
there's nothing that like you and I
could say to make it better but you know
I know I don't want to make AI I don't
want to make this about me in any way
shape or form because it is not about me
but I know what it's like to lose a
parent and it's never easy what I want
is to have as much support there for him
as possible if you can send him a
message send him some love send him
anything just you don't have to there's
no obligation to do this but if you want
to reach out do I think he would make
the world the difference there's
unfortunately I hate to pile on bad news
one on top of the other but I was back
in Cincinnati talking to my stepmom and
you know she told me about her nephew
Jay who I had only met three four times
in my entire life I never really knew
him but he was part of my stepmoms
family and I care about my stepmom very
much
so she told me that Jay was killed he
was shot works in security and you know
he was shot there is a a GoFundMe set up
because Jay was a single dad of three
kids basically what's gonna happen with
the money is the money is gonna go into
a trust it's gonna pay for those kids
education there's no obligation to help
but I made a promise that I would let
you guys know if you want there's a link
in the description that goes to the
GoFundMe please
give if you can there's no obligation I
wish that I had like a good ending for
this video a happy ending or something
like that but I don't sometimes life
just really sucks and the only thing
that we can do even if it's a stranger
reaching out to someone that they have
never known is show your support send
some love send some goodwill and try to
make someone's day just a little bit
brighter so if you can please do and
thank you so much I will get back into
making videos obviously I don't want
anyone to make this about me in any way
shape or form do not go oh I feel so bad
for mark this has nothing to do with me
I mean it's my friend and it's my family
but this is not about me this is about
the people that are hurting this is
about the family that was torn apart
this is about Tyler my friend who is in
pain right now pain that I know very
well and he could use some love right
now and my stepmoms family could use a
lot of love right now so please send
whatever you can I will get back into
the swing of things as soon as I get a
little sleep and thank you everybody so
much for watching
and I'll see you in the next one bye